voilà pour cette prise de parole dans
tony blinken de secrétaire d'état
américain qui est en visite il faut le
dire à à genève là où il a pu rencontrer
à sergueï lavrov le chef de la
diplomatie russe on va en parler
justement de cette rencontre avec vous
bruno daroux mais aussi avec notre
invité anastasia à chapeau qui n'a
maître de conférences en géopolitique à
sciences po et spécialiste de la russie
merci à vous deux d'être à mes côtés
pour continuer à en parler d'abord bruno
on a vu des échanges des discussions
mais pour l'heure pas d'avancer les deux
parties se donnent rendez vous la
semaine prochaine oui alors on peut dire
que sur la forme la bonne nouvelle c'est
que les deux parties acceptent de
continuer à se parler et là anthony
blinken là encore dix ans on va
continuer à parler pour voir si on peut
arranger les choses par la voie de la
diplomatie et en dialoguant donc ce qui
veut dire que on en est pas à la rupture
que le dialogue est maintenu mais sur le
fond clairement chacun comme sur ses
positions ce que sergueï lavrov présenté
comme une concession le fait que les
états unis vont répondre par écrit aux
deux préoccupations essentielles de la
russie concernant l'élargissement de
l'otan à l'est et notamment en ukraine
et puis l'arrêt des manoeuvres
militaires dans les pays d'europe de
l'est anthony blinken a dit oui on va
répondre aux préoccupations de la russie
mais on va aussi exprimé par écrit nos
préoccupations puis on va essayer de
présenter quelques idées pour faire
baisser la tension mais sur le contenu
de ce qui va être répondu par écrit par
les américains la semaine prochaine il
est très peu probable que les américains
et les occidentaux plus globalement
change d'avis sur la demande de moscou
concernant notamment l'otan derrière
anthony blinken a répété que la
politique de la porte ouverte de l'otan
était un principe absolument fondamental
et qu'il était hors de question de
reculer là-dessus donc en fait chacun
campe sur ses positions
sergueï lavrov lui explique que ce sont
les occidentaux qui présentent une
menace les occidentaux disent que bon la
russie affirme ce qu'a répété sergey la
voie qu'elle ne veut pas envahir
l'ukraine et bien dit anthony blinken si
c'est le cas que moscou retire ses
troupes et tout ira bien
anastasia chapochnikov excusez-moi
chapeau qui n'a excusez-moi j'ai écorché
votre nom vous est maître de conférences
en géopolitique à sciences po et
spécialiste de la russie je le disais un
peu plus tôt avant cette rencontre avec
sergueï lavrov le le secrétaire d'état
américain a pris soin tout de même
d'aller voir ses alliés d'aller voir ses
homologues allemands français et
britanniques est ce que le fait de
parler d'une seule et même voix a
réellement un impact sur un chef d'état
comme vladimir poutine
c'est plutôt un défi pour l'occident de
parler d'un seul et même endroit et de
plus les négociations continuent le plus
difficile ce sera déjà les
prononciations de la république tchèque
les dernières annonces de brice dans
mâcon en témoigne bien sûr pendant l'été
justement ce dernier pendant la
négociation c'est compliqué entre temps
que les riches des etats unis quand les
états unis sont censés de présenter le
front unique de l'occident cependant
juste avant sa dévotion de l'a77
dernière étape aujourd'hui on a le
président de la france qui a un nom ce
que ce serait vraiment pas mal d'avoir
un a donc l architecture de sécurité
séparé européenne et c'est quelque chose
que ce à quoi manuel mann contient
depuis un moment c'est quelque chose de
si et correspond à 100% de discours
officiel du kremlin depuis une très
longue date ne s'est pas un événement
non plus et donc c'était sans surprise
remarqué par
servir la bôve pendant sa conférence de
presse tout à l'heure comme en
développement plutôt positif et ne ne
perçoit pas du tout en tant que menace
pour la russie et ne perçoit pas du tout
cette annonce en tant que menace pour la
russie parce que bien sûr c'est plutôt
pour lui un signe que l'occident n'est
pas à temps unis que il veut ensemble et
et le fait même l'importance de ces
négociations c'est pas
bien sûr ce n'est pas le résultat que
l'occident accepte toutes les conditions
de la russie c'est pour ça que c'est un
outil mathon tu vois ton qui bien
évidemment peut pas être entièrement
accepté mais on doit se demander qu'est
ce qu'est la véritable jeu type du
kremlin si moscou à vous
envahir l'ukraine mais ils pourraient le
faire à n'importe quel moment on ne peut
pas faire toutes ces négociations de ce
processus et faire naître plusieurs
dénonciations plusieurs mois de la force
militaire pour le faire
ce que on va aussi très bien le rendu de
toutes ces négociations et leur du bas
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant avril
l'année dernière c'est les rencontres
régulier systématique formelle au très
haut niveau entre la russie et les etats
unis la russie et maintenant aussi
l'otan donc l'or l'élévation de la
réussir on peut dire au statut
diplomatique où êtes-vous nous être
depuis 2014 et cette évolution que la
version que l'a perdue depuis 2014 et le
retour à cette position de grands
pouvoirs ou la vessie veut se voir et
vous être aperçu comme ça grâce à une
menace donc pas grâce à des changements
de son attitude ou à toutes les
conditions que l'occident a lancé
apparemment mais grâce à justement un
durcissement de cette position et quand
on voit cette résultats et on voit aussi
comment elle est soit sergueï lavrov
soit pas restes d'un petit pendant sa
conférence par décembre comment ils ont
l'air vraiment content et satisfait avec
elles souligne toujours avec le cours
des négociations
on se demande est-ce que c'est pas ça
une véritable objectif de moscou c'est
ce qu'elle n'annule pas donc la
possibilité d'un vision mais ce qui nous
interpelle est ce que parce que ça c'est
vraiment résultat comparé clairement
achevée c'est très intéressant ce que
vous dites vous dit en gros si la russie
voulait envahir l'ukraine elle n'aurait
pas pris le temps de discuter elle y
serait allé c'est quoi en réalité c'est
un coup de bluff le plus important tu
leur as du marketing c'est de continuer
à être très présent sur la scène
internationale à ce qu'on parle de lui
être présent aux plus grandes
négociations
politiques et géopolitiques j'ai envie
de dire
je pense que c'est très important pour
continuer notre d'être vraiment
considéré comme
haut rang mondial régional se vend et on
va bien tant tous ces manoeuvres
militaires ont commencé avril donc juste
quelques mois après mais vers la
présidence du nouveau président
américain joe biden doit elle mettait
tout de suite des steppes à moscou et
moscou a tout de suite obtenu à notre
tour d'elle-même
sur dans le format de négociations
bilatérales
format de la guerre froide et sans doute
c'était c'est
le fait qu'on est toujours là
aujourd'hui et commencent à avancer le
fait que les russies maintenant nous
imposer son propre agenda a le temps sur
le futur de l'otan parce que même si
elle est unie où les partenaires de
l'otan disent oui ou non
moscou ne fait que c'était sujet de la
future de l'otan et maintenant imposées
par la russie ne fait que les états unis
se trouvent à la défensive en besoin de
répondre aux demandes russe sur le sujet
qui ne à
de l'organisation donc la russie ne fait
pas partie ça montre déjà énorme montée
diplomatique en puissance de la russie
et ensuite
on a visiblement un petit problème de
connexion avec notre invité bruno daroux
on parlait justement de ces sanctions
que les états unis brandissent
injustement pour tenter de retenir
moscou à des sanctions promises les
l'union européenne se dit prête elle
aussi à en prendre mais le fait que ce
soit justement les états unis qui mène
ces négociations le fait que ce soit
anthony blinken qui traverse
l'atlantique pour venir en parler c'est
pas un aveu de faiblesse avait déjà des
européens alors que c'est parce qu'ici
elle
contient des trop dit à l'instant parce
que c'est l'obsession de vladimir
poutine c'est que la russie retrouve son
rang béland des superpuissances comme à
l'époque de la guerre froide donc de ce
point de vue là vladimir poutine il
s'est dit pour obtenir ça il faut que je
frappe fort que je menace fort donc
effectivement il à hilla
hamas et ses troupes à la frontière de
l'ukraine pour faire réagir l'autre
partie est dans la réaction de l'autre
partie de l'occident mais il a
délibérément mis de côté les européens
parce qu'il ya quand même un reproche de
la part de la russie sur la manière dont
la france et l'allemagne dans le cas des
accords de minsk selon moscou les
européens n'ont pas fait leur travail
auprès de kiev serre n'ont pas réussi à
convaincre kiev d'accorder un statut
spécial au donbass et puis il ya le fait
de dire bon ben moi les français les
allemands c'est c'est moyennement
important moi je parle directement
effectivement aux états unis parce que
je suis redevenu la super puissance ce
qui est d'un certain côté peut pas être
un peu puéril quand on pense aux enjeux
du cou qui sont en jeu précisément le
fait que tout ce qui intéresse vladimir
poutine en fait c'est d'apparaître comme
une superpuissance alors effectivement
de ce point de vue là d'un point de vue
tactique il réussit ce sont les les
états unis effectivement qui viennent
négocier avec lui après il faut jamais
oublier cc c'est sans doute vrai que les
occidentaux les américains notamment le
savez même les européens c'est à dire
que la russie a réussi à être à nouveau
un acteur très important sur le devant
de la scène internationale grâce à
effectivement à cet interventionnisme de
l'avenir protein mais on sait très bien
que économiquement parlant c'est pas la
chine à la russie ce n'est que la
onzième puissance économique mondiale
loin derrière les etats-unis la chine la
france l'allemagne le royaume-uni
l'italie donc c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs et en voilà un un pays
économiquement pas très important
finalement pour jouer dans dans la cour
deux superpuissances que
diplomatiquement ylang-ylang il il en
fait beaucoup si je puis dire pour
réimposer effectivement ce face à face
donc pour le moment vu la manière dont
il agit les occidentaux sont obligés de
réagir on verra après la question c'est
moi je suis assez d'accord avec
l'intervenante 1 il pense pas que les
russes aient l'intention de d'envahir
lucrin seulement ils vont même maintenir
cette menace le temps qu'il faut
procéder d'obtenir quelque chose de la
part des occidentaux parce que c'est
important en soi oui mais effectivement
pour montrer que la russie est une
grande puissance problème c'est que dans
la durée ça entretient un climat qui
peut quand même faire déraper les choses
car si ses troupes restent massés
semaines et des semaines les risques de
dérapage augmente aussi c'est un peu le
côté risque et de la stratégie de
vladimir poutine et plus vagney routine
il voit aussi que c'est un installé le
tête à tête où la rivalité comme on
voudra entre washington et pékin il veut
lui revenir aussi dans cette dans cette
course-là être présent à tout prix à la
table des négociations pour les dossiers
les plus brûlants de la planète merci
bruno daroux pour cette analyse ensuite
à cette rencontre on le disait entre
anthony blinken et et ça gagne lavrov
s'est